nous poursuivons notre périple à bord du
transsibérien avec notre correspondant
jean françois bélanger il fait escale ce
soir en sibérie pour nous présenter une
facette aussi méconnue que surprenant de
cette partie de la russie
il a rencontré des jeunes filles qui
rêvent un jour de quitter les montagnes
et le froid pour déambuler sur les
podiums des plus grands défilés de mode
de la planète
notre étape du jour nous emmène à
novossibirsk
à 2800 km à l'est de moscou la troisième
plus grande ville de russie est aussi la
capitale de la sibérie une région
souvent associé aux grands froids dans
l'imaginaire populaire
mais dans le milieu de la mode la
sibérie à une tout autre image
on y trouve du temps les plus belles
femmes au monde
les pelles de sibérie attire des agences
de mannequins de partout à travers la
planète à la recherche de la perle rare
quatre fois par année à nay jacquot va
sillonne la région pour tenter d'y
dénicher la future kate moss dans chaque
ville traversée elle organise un casting
où affluent par douzaines d jeune fille
plein d'espoir quand la caméra spéciale
donnant cette maladie
anna est ce qu'on appelle dans le milieu
une scop une découvreuse de talents king
for growth nous cherchons des filles qui
souhaitent en mesure de voyager autour
du monde juste mon expérience je me base
sur la propre expérience
quand il ya du potentiel je lis est un
as travaille pour une agence russe mais
ses principaux clients se trouvent à
paris et à new york
les deux capitales mondiales de la mode
est aujourd'hui stéphane ababou je suis
garante de la prestigieuse agence
marilyn à paris a fait le déplacement en
personne pour moi dont le ps en général
et notamment en russie
les filles sont très très belle vraiment
ils ont un vivier extraordinaire
un métissage incroyable pourra venir
jusqu'ici parce que ce allez juste à
moscou et saint pétersbourg ce serait
trop simple
donc c'est bien aussi d'aller à la
source la présence de stéphane fait
monter d'un cran la nervosité dans la
salle pour toutes les jeunes filles
présentes le parisien détient les clés
de la célébrité
mais le processus de sélection est
sévère et placards marina corps tout va
par exemple impressionne stéphane par sa
beauté mais avec un tour de hanche de 93
cm elle est jugée trop grasse marée
d'une très bonne une chance une et
encore c'est une agence qui est très
sélective on travaille plus sur la
qualité des soins que sous la quantité
taille minimum 1 m 75 tour de hanches
maximum 90 cm les critères sont très
précis et très serré et le ruban à
mesurer ne pardonne pas
pêche au maroc forte du père de stéphane
anastasia hammam et eva sort rapidement
du lot
à 21 ans elle a déjà d'expérience à
voyager en europe et en asie elle a même
eu droit à quelques couvertures de
magazines stéphane prend quelques photos
tourner quelques vidéos promet de la
recontacter pour elle c'est déjà leur
être sous sanaa et stéphane pas le temps
de s'attarder à pen castel terminé tous
deux se rendent à la gare pour prendre
un train de nuit
leur traversée de sibérie ne fait que
commencer une routine que hannah répète
maintenant depuis cinq ans elle même
ancien mannequin originaire de la région
elle tire une grande fierté à faire
connaître à l'étranger le charme
incomparable des belles de sibérie c'est
la sibérie est une très grande région et
plusieurs tops modèles viennent ici la
raison c'est qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
mélanges entre personnes de différentes
origines du kazakhstan de l'extrême
orient ce et aussi de tous ces gens qui
ont été emprisonné en sibérie
ça donne des visages très intéressant au
petit matin
à peine arrivé la tournée se poursuit au
patch à notre place d'un outil servant
progrès mois
casting la moyenne d'âge est rarement
très élevé la plupart des participantes
sont adolescente certaine à peine
pubères
sacha personnes aqoba par exemple n'a
que 12 ans ce qui n'empêche pas de
retenir l'attention d'anna et de
stéphane
she's il ya un match est ce qu'elle est
jeune mais elle a commencé comme
mannequin quand elle avait 9 ans elle
est très disciplinée pour son âge qui
nous ne poussons pas des filles à
travailler si elles ne sont pas prêtes à
accoucher en gros stéphane lui ne peut
employer de mannequins de moins de 16
ans mais il commence à les suivre bien
plus jeune histoire d'avoir un peu
d'avancé sur ses concurrents c'est juste
en fait un pari sur l'avenir
quand on voit son évolution et puis oui
ou non si ça marche ou pas quoi
à 15 ans questi nature est là elle est
déjà presque prête pour farid
elle a passé un an à l'école de
mannequins de novossibirsk appris
l'anglais de façon intensive et a perdu
pas mal de poids le château intéressante
n'est pas encore in shape
mais elle a que 15 ans donc je vois un
peu son évolution officiel mais gris on
va voir un peu comment va changer même
son visage va s'affiner et elle est
intéressante je suis pas certain mais
c'est ça vaut le coup de suivre
j'espérais vraiment être choisie car
j'adore new york et paris avoir la
chance de travailler
c'est vraiment une nouvelle étape dans
ma carrière c'est génial est prête mais
une carrière de top model international
n'est pas à portée de tous à la
seleccion une quarantaine de mannequins
chaque mois pour des contrats à
l'étranger mais de ce nombre
seule une infime partie accédera dispo
matri vedettes comme paris et new york
après le casting place au défilé un peu
de poudre et les adolescentes se
transforme en femme fatale
s'il est organisé pour le marché local
ce défilé de mode est aussi l'occasion
pour les aspirants top model de montrer
ce qu'elles savent faire une deuxième
chance d'impressionner anna et stéphane
défilé est aussi un concours et stéphane
fait partie du jury
dans les coulisses christina a du mal à
cacher sa nervosité
elle sait que ce soir est important
c'est toujours bien de pouvoir observer
les mannequins travail et les regarder
bouger dans un défilé
ça permet de les voir sous un autre
angle on peut déjà les imaginer dans des
conditions réelles
au final tout s'est bien passé pour
christina bien en évidence dans le
défilé elle a participé à la
présentation de trois collections
les vêtements étaient magnifiques
l'ambiance géniale c'est super pour elle
le rêve est maintenant à portée de main
même si elle sait le chemin à parcourir
est encore très long
notre périple en train se poursuit
demain et nous emmène vers des petites
localités isolées de sibérie ou le
chemin de fer est une véritable ligne de
vie demain et et journal vous emmène
visiter un train hôpital qui offre des
soins de première classe aux habitants
des villages les plus éloignés de russie
et je vous invite à consulter le carnet
de voyage de jean françois avec de
magnifiques photos des commentaires et
des compléments d'informations rendez
vous sur notre site internet à l'adresse
que vous voyez à l'écran